so we've been going through all of the
other things that we were assuming are
held constant in order to be moving
along one demand curve and now let's
list a few other and before i do any
more of them let's talk about the ones
we already talked about so one we said
that one of the things we held constant
let me write this down so held constant
held
constant
one of the things that we held constant
on the to move along one demand curve
for the demand itself to not shift for
the curve to not shift is price of
related goods
price
of
related
goods the other thing we assumed that's
being held constant is price
expectations for our good
price expectations
and now we'll list a couple of them that
are fairly intuitive but you'll see in
the next few videos that they're often
special cases even to this
so the other thing that we we've been
holding constant to stay on one demand
curve is income is income and this one
is fairly intuitive if what happens if
everyone's income were to increase and
in real terms it were to actually
increase well then all of a sudden they
have more disposable income maybe to
spend on something like ebooks and so
for any given price point the demand
would increase and so it would increase
the demand and once again when we talk
about increasing demand we're talking
about shifting the entire curve we're
not talking about a particular quantity
of demand so income goes up then it
increases demand
demand
demand goes up and remember when we're
talking about income when demand goes up
we're talking about the whole curve
shifting to the right at any given price
point we are probably we're going to
have a larger quantity demanded so the
whole curve this whole demand schedule
would change and likewise if income went
down demand would go down and we're
going to see in a future video it's
actually quite interesting that's not
always not the case this is only true
for normal goods
this is only true for normal goods
normal goods and in a future video we'll
see
goods called inferior goods where this
is not necessarily the case or by
definition for an inferior good it would
not be the case now the other ones that
are somewhat intuitive are population
population once again
if population goes up obviously for any
at any given price point more people
will want it so it would shift the
demand curve to the right or it would
increase demand if population were to go
down it would decrease demand which
means shifting the whole curve to the
left and then the last one we'll talk
about and remember we're holding all of
these things constant in order for
demand not to change the last thing is
just
is just preferences we're assuming that
people's tastes and preferences don't
change while we move along a specific
demand curve
if preferences actually change then it
will change the curve so for example if
all of a sudden um i'm i'm you know the
author of the book is on some very
popular show talk show that tells
everyone that this is the best book that
would ever written then preferences
would go up and that would increase the
total demand at any given price point
more people would be willing to buy the
book if on the other hand on that same
talk show it turns out that they do an
expose on the author having this you
know sorted past and the author
plagiarized the whole book then the
demand will go down the entire curve
regardless of the price point at any
given price point the quantity demanded
will actually will actually go down